[Musique]
après une crise comme nous venons de la
vivre on a un président de la république
était incapable de fixer un cadre de
fixer une orientation est choisie ait
choisi un nom premier ministre parce que
la réalité c'est que sur ce type de
profil il ya plus de premier ministre
plus ce sentiment que c'est le choix
d'un collaborateur d'un secrétaire
généralde d'un permanent qui va être là
pour faire le pour faire le travail
technique qui peut y avoir comme quand
on gère les affaires courantes d'une
entreprise qui va fermer et bien bon ce
qui frappe dans la nomination de jean
castex c'est son profil bon c'est un
homme semble-t-il très estimable mais
enfin il a un profil qui n'est pas
politique qui est un profil
technocratique c'est un haut
fonctionnaire au moins les tournages et
emmanuel macron et je les sens assez peu
ils sont tellement répété que j'ai un
peu de mal à y croire toute addiction
pareil c'est ce qu'il importe c'est le
débat d'idées le fourn fans de dépasser
des clivages partisans et il avait dit
vous allez voir un espoir renaît tout va
bien se passer en france
eh bien on voit le résultat n'ont jamais
la france n'a été aussi fracturé il faut
de la clarté pour nos électeurs et une
fois plus l'enseignement des élections
municipales c'est qu'il faut de la
clarté et nous notre clarté est très
simple c'est que nous ne sommes pas la
république en marche nous sommes même en
opposition à la république en marre nous
n'avons pas du tout la même vision que
le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron qu'il
s'agisse de l'explosion de la dette
publique qu'il s'agisse des sujets sur
le régalien qu'il s'agisse des
territoires nous n'avons pas du tout la
même vision de la france et il est temps
que ça change
et puis surtout qui est des vraies
décisions politiques qui soient prises
un vrai projet aujourd'hui on voit qu'on
va dans le mur
on a vu d'ailleurs les résultats au
moment des municipales pour la
république en marche qui était désastre
on voit bien que la force politique
aujourd'hui c'est la droite cds
république a d'ailleurs s'ils sont
obligés de venir piocher chez nous pour
avoir des candidats c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont personne chez eux
donc là il est dans une situation qui
est quand même très gai
présent à un public et il faut qu'ils
qu'il arriva sur les avants quelque part
on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'il n'a plus
les ressorts politiques n'a plus les
ressorts politiques parce que c'est
l'échec le plus cuisant aux municipales
jamais un président de la république il
ya un tel échec aux élections
municipales ce qu'elles sont il les
français attendent de l'autorité vous
avez vu l'état du pays ils attendent une
réduction des inégalités
vous avez vu l'état du pays la réduction
des fractures
la réduction aussi la plus de
reconnaissance de revalorisation du du
du travail ils veulent de la
responsabilité dans le respect la
stratégie elle est limpide aujourd'hui
c'est de siphonner l'électorat de droite
je doute de sa capacité à se réinventer
vous savez je suis très sceptique il
nous avait promis aussi un virage un
acte ii du quinquennat après le gilet
jaune est ce que vous l'avez vu passer
je me fiche du casting
je me fiche du casting le problème c'est
pas le casting le problème c'est pour
quoi faire
aujourd'hui c'est pour quoi faire la
france elle a besoin un peu de
clarification sur ce que le gouvernement
fait concrètement
moi je ne sais pas où le président de la
république va donc pour ce qui est
composé le gouvernement
on lui fait confiance vous savez il
ouvrira le gotha mondain et va bien
trouver du monde à mettre dans le
gouvernement
mais quels cas pour aller où pour porter
quelles réformes donc voilà la situation
et il faut un nouveau cap il faut que ce
cap il soit clair à ce défi là d'aller
convaincre celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui sûrement sont des déçus de
la macro ni mais aussi d'autres espaces
politiques
c'est la grande ambition les
républicains c'est pas d'être seulement
à la hauteur des républicains c'est
d'être à la hauteur des français
[Musique]